for me breath works really important
because i really feel that we experience
one of two things we're either
experiencing our mind ahead of our body
so everyone's had that experience with
their minds racing and the body's like
oh i'm just tired put me back in bed or
we experience the other extreme which is
the mind's feeling really tired and the
body's having to rush around it's the
mind's like oh give me a break but the
body's like no but i need to do this and
this and so for me breath work really
realigns my mind and my body in the
morning and brings it back together
because when i wake up i can be really
creative sometimes but oh my god i've
got a million ideas of videos i want to
make and i'm like no look just calm down
the body's not ready yet you know or you
wake up and if you do which i've i
really avoid now but if you do look at
your phone first thing you've got all
these messages coming in your mind has
to go from zero to 100 miles per hour in
two seconds literally like the fastest
car in the world and the body's just
like oh look just give me a break i just
woke up and so for me the passenger
breath work just allows me to align my
body and mind so that's why i do